THE BREAKING NEWS WE ARE
FOLLOWING THIS MORNING.
PAUL PELOSI, THE HUSBAND OF
NANCY PELOSI, HOSPITALIZED AT
THIS HOUR AFTER BEING ATTACKED
WITH A HAMMER AT THE COUPLE'S
HOME IN SAN FRANCISCO OVERNIGHT.
WE DO HAVE OUR CORRESPONDENTS
AND NAUMS STANDING BY.
I WANT TO BEGIN WITH MANU RAJU.
WE'RE HEARING FROM THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE ABOUT THIS INCIDENT.
WHAT MORE DO WE KNOW ABOUT THE
ATTACK?
>> Reporter: WE'RE STILL
LEARNING MORE ABOUT THE STUNNING
ATTACK.
SHE WAS NOT THERE AT TIME BUT
HER HUSBAND, PAUL PELOSI, WHO
WAS 82 YEARS OLD WAS AT THE
TIME.
AND WHAT WAE'RE LEARNING IS AN
ASSAIL AENT BROKE INTO THE
COUPLE'S HOME AND ATTACKED PAUL
PELOSI WITH A HAMMER.
THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE PUT OUT A
STATEMENT OF WHAT THEY BELIEVE
HAS HAPPENED.
THEY SAID EARLY THIS MORNING AN
ASSAILANT BROKE INTO THE PELOSI
RESIDENT IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
VIOLENTLY ASSAULTED MR. PELOSI.
THE ASSAILANT IS IN CUSTODY AND
THE MOTIVATION IS UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
MR. PELOSI WAS TAKEN TO THE
HOSPITAL WHERE HE IS RECEIVING
EXCELLENT MEDICAL CARE AND THE
SPEAKER WAS NOT IN SAN FRANCISCO
AT THE TIME.
WE HAVE LEARNED THAT THE SPEAKER
WAS IN D.C. AT THE TIME.
SHE'S BEEN TRAVELING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY RAISING MONEY, APPEARING
IN CAMPAIGN STOPS AS WE HEAD
INTO THE CRITICAL MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
SOMETIMES PAUL PELOSI TRAVELS
WITH HER AND OFTENTIMES HE DOES
NOT.
HE HAS HIS OWN COMPANY, A
FINANCIAL LEASING SERVICES
COMPANY.
HE'S 82 YEARS OLD.
HE WAS IN THE NEWS RECENTLY, WAS
PLEADING GUILTY TO DRIVING UNDER
THE INFLUENCE IN AUGUST.
BUT THIS COMES ALSO AS THREATS
OF POLITICAL VIOLENCE AND ACTUAL
POLITICAL VIOLENCE HAVE BEEN
PLAYING OUT IN ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AS WE HEAD INTO THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
FEARS OVER ELECTION WORKER
SAFETY ALIKE.
WE DON'T KNOW THE MOTIVATION OF
WHAT EXACTLY WHY THIS ASSAILANT
BROKE INTO THE PELOSI HOME.
WHETHER IT WAS POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED OR NOT.
THAT IS STILL UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
WE'LL LEARN MORE AND REPORT THAT
WHEN WE LEARN MORE ABOUT IT.
BUT A STAGGERING AND SCARY
MOMENT AT THE PELOSI HOME AS THE
SPEAKER'S HUSBAND ATTACKED BY A
HAMMER.
>> WE'LL CONTINUE TO STAY IN
TOUCH AS YOU HAVE THE
DEVELOPMENTS.
>>> ALSO JOINING ME NOW, LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND INTELLIGENCE
ANALYST JON MILLER AND FORMER
D.C. METROPOLITAN POLICE OFFICER
MICHAEL FANONE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH.
IF WE LOOK AT WHAT WE DON'T
KNOW.
BUT THERE IS A SUSPECT IN
CUSTODY.
THIS IS WHAT WAS REFERRED TO AS
A VIOLENTLY ASSAULTED ACCORDING
TO THE STATEMENT FROM THE
SPEAKER AS OFFICE AND LEARNED
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT A
HAMMER WAS USED.
AS YOUR PUTTING THESE PIECES
TOGETHER.
WHAT ARE THE FIRST QUESTIONS
YOU'RE ASKING?
>> WHAT WE'RE SEE RIGHT NOW IS
YOU HAVE A 32-YEAR-OLD MAN IN
CUSTODY.
HE COMES INTO THE HOME AFTER
2:00 A.M. WITH A HAMMER.
AND ATTACKS THE RESIDENTS THERE
WHO HAPPENS TO BE MR. PELOSI.
SO YOU START OFF YOUR QUESTIONS
WITH WHERE WAS HE TAKEN INTO
CUSTODY?
WAS HE TAKEN INTO CUSTODY IN THE
HOME, AT WHICH POINT
IDENTIFICATION BECOMES MUCH
STRONGER.
OR BASED ON THE DESCRIPTION
OUTSIDE OF THE HOME IN THE AREA
PICKED UP BY POLICE.
WE DON'T KNOW THAT YET.
WHAT STATEMENTS DID HE MAKE
BEFORE OR DURING THIS ATTACK.
OR AFTER IT TO POLICE.
ARE THEY POLITICALLY STATEMENTS,
IRRATIONAL STATEMENTS OR WAS HE
THERE FOR SOMETHING ELSE.
THIS IS -- THIS IS A DAY AFTER
WE DID EXTENSIVE REPORTING ON A
THREAT ASSESSMENT BASED ON THE
POLITICAL CLIMATE.
WE STILL DON'T KNOW IF THIS HAS
ANYTHING TO DO WITH THAT.
BUT THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE IS
AN ENORMOUSLY POWERFUL OFFICIAL
IN THE SCOPE OF THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT IN THE LINE OF
SUCCESSION AND RECEIVES 24 HOUR
PROTECTION FROM THE CAPITOL
POLICE WHEN SHE TRAVELS TO
PLACES LIKE NEW YORK, SHE SEES
ADDITIONAL PROTECTION FROM THE
NYPD AND THE SAME IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
BUT FAMILY MEMBERS, AS WE SEE
HERE, COULD BE VULNERABLE.
SO THERE IS A LOT TO ASK STILL.
>> AND IN TERMS OF SECURITY, I'M
CURIOUS, YOUR TIME THERE IN
WASHINGTON, TO SEE WE'VE TALKED
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
ABOUT HOW THE DIFFERENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WITHIN THE
DISTRICT WORK TOGETHER AND HOW
SPECIFICALLY THAT COME NEWS PLAY
WHEN IT IS ABOUT SECURITY FOR A
LAWMAKER.
IT WAS JOHN WAS POINTING OUT,
THE FAMILY IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT.
WOULD PAUL PELOSI HAVE HAD EXTRA
SECURITY, ESPECIALLY IF HE WAS
IN HOME CALIFORNIA VERSUS BEING
IN WASHINGTON, D.C. WITH THE
SPEAKER?
>> IT IS DOUBTFUL.
U.S. CAPITOL POLICE I THINK IS
WHOLLY UNPREPARED, UNDERSTAFFED
TO TAKE ON THE RISE IN
SUBSTANTIATED THREATS AGAINST
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
I THINK THEY'RE SIMPLY
UNDERSTAFFED.
>> SO IF THEY'RE SIMPLY
UNDERSTAFFED AND WE LOOK AT THE
RISE THAT WE HAVE SEEN IN
RHETORIC, THE RISE IN THREATS
AND AGAIN IT IS IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT AS BOTH MANU AND JOHN
HAVE SAID, WE DON'T KNOW THE
MOTIVATION FOR THIS ATTACK.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THERE IS
ANYTHING POLITICAL BEHIND IT BUT
WE CAN'T IGNORE THE WARNINGS
FROM NYPD IN NEW YORK CITY AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ABOUT VIOLENT
RHETORIC.
AND MICHAEL FANONE, YOU KNOW
BETTER THAN ANYONE WHAT THAT
COULD TRANSLATE TO WHEN YOU LOOK
AT WHAT WE DO KNOW, WHAT IS YOUR
MAJOR CONCERN THIS MORNING?
>> MY MAJOR CONCERN IS THAT THE
RHETORIC THAT INSPIRED THE
ATTACK ON THE CAPITOL AND THE
RHETORIC THAT CONTINUES TO
INSPIRE INDIVIDUALS TO COMMIT
ACTS OF VIOLENCE FOR POLITICAL
REASONS CONTINUES, UNCHECKED.
AND UNFORTUNATELY IT SEEMS AS
THOUGH OUR APPETITE FOR THE
INSPIRATION OF JANUARY 6 HAS
WANED.
IT HASN'T BEEN A MAJOR PART OF
THE CONVERSATION GOING INTO THE
MIDTERMS.
AND THOSE RESPONSIBLE HAVE YET
TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
AND THAT BEING SAID, I KNOW THAT
FROM THE MANY MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS THAT I SPEAK TO, JUST
LIKE MYSELF, HAVE HAD TO SEEK
PRIVATE CONTRACTORS TO PROVIDE
SECURITY.
THEM BECAUSE U.S. CAPITOL POLICE
IS UNEQUIPPED AND ME, BECAUSE I
HAVE NO OTHER ALTERNATIVE.
BUT FOR THOSE OF US THAT T
CONTINUE TO SPEAK OUT AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP, THOSE THREATS ARE
AN EVERY DAY REALITY.
>> WHEN WE LOOK AT HOW THIS IS
GOING TO COME TOGETHER, IN TERMS
OF THE CAPITOL POLICE, AND
WHITNEY WILD WAS REPORTED THEY
HAVE A NUMBER OF FIELD OFFICES
AND THERE IS A FIELD OFFICE IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
HOW CLOSE -- HOW QUICKLY DOES,
FOR EXAMPLE, THE SFPD AND
CAPITOL POLICE IN THAT FIELD
OFFICE OR FBI, WHO WAS INVOLVED,
HOW QUICKLY ARE THEY WORKING
TOGETHER.
>> THAT IS ALL HAPPEN RIGHT NOW.
AND I MEAN, THIS IS -- THE
GAME-CHANGER HERE IS THERE IS A
SUSPECT IN CUSTODY.
THAT SPEEDS THIS UP ENORMOUSLY,
WHICH IS -- AND WE'RE DOING THE
SAME THING RIGHT NOW.
WE'RE LOOKING AT HIS NAME AND
HIS BACKGROUND, LOOKING AT HIS
SOCIAL MEDIA.
BECAUSE THAT IS GOING TO TELL US
POTENTIALLY A LITTLE BIT.
BUT THE FBI WILL COME INTO THIS
RIGHT AWAY.
IS THIS AN ACT OF TERRORISM?
WHO IS THIS GUY?
WHAT IS HIS BACK GROUND?
THEY HAVE JURISDICTION FOR
ASSAULT ON GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
OR THE FAMILY MEMBER OF A
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL IF THAT IS
MEANT TO INTIMIDATE A GOVERNMENT
OFFICIAL.
THE CAPITOL POLICE IS PRIMARY
FOR THE PROTECTION OF NANCY
PELOSI, FOR THREATS AGAINST
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
THEY'LL BE IN THERE RIGHT NOW
ASSESSING WHAT DOES THIS ATTACK
MEAN.
WHO IS THIS GUY, WHERE IS HE
FROM, WAS IT POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED?
>> WAS THE PELOSI THE INTENDED
TARGET.
>> DOES THAT RADIATE THAT OUT TO
OTHER MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
SO IT IS BEGINNING TO CHURN AS
THEY START TO DIG INTO THE
BACKGROUND OF THE OFFENDERS AND
ANY STAPLES HE MADE AND PRIMARY
HERE, BECAUSE AS WE SAY IN THE
POLICE BUSINESS, THEY HAVE THE
COLLAR, IS THE SAN FRANCISCO
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
THIS IS THEIR ARREST.
IT COULD BE SUPERCEDED FEDERALLY
BUT THOSE STATE CHARGES ARE WHAT
THEY COULD HOLD THIS INDIVIDUAL
ON.
AND THEY ARE PROBABLY THE FIRST
PEOPLE OTHER THAN THE VICTIM,
MR. PELOSI, TO HAVE SPOKEN TO
THIS INDIVIDUAL.
AND WHAT HE SAID IN THOSE
STATEMENT IS KEY.
>> APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU, ALL.